[Musica]
[Applauso]
flacco mi rialzo sono stanco i
neozelandesi sono in troppi dall'altro
lato dell'arac faccio il giro e mi
schiero come secondo difensore
respiro affannosamente per recuperare lo
sforzo ma non c'è tempo la palla sta
uscendo
l'apertura blacks attacca la linea e noi
saliamo
passa la palla ad un compagno
all'interno proprio di fronte a me è un
attimo a lungo abbraccio arrivo sulla
palla la porta al petto e corro corro
corro più veloce che posso non penso a
nulla
quelli sono i 50 metri più lunghi belli
e leggeri di tutta la mia vita
mi volto per capire se qualcuno mi sta
prendendo ma non riesco nemmeno a
mettere a fuoco quello che succede
voglio solo correre e raggiungere la
meta
ci sono ecco i pali supera la linea mi
tuffo quel pallone sul petto e lo
schiaccia a terra
quello al momento più bello disteso su
prato umido per qualche istante prima
che i miei compagni mi sommergano di
abbracci e tutto vero
ho 21 anni sono capitano sto giocando
contro gli all blacks ed appena segnato
la mia prima meta in nazionale
tutti noi sogniamo quando siamo giovani
sognano di diventare astronauti medici
pompieri giocatori di rugby che molte
altre cose
quello che separa però veramente un
sogno da tutto il resto è il fatto di
essere quasi irraggiungibile
quando immaginiamo l'impossibile e non
abbiamo idea del percorso per
raggiungerlo
ecco in quel momento stiamo veramente
sognando ma un sogno per avere una
chance di potersi realizzare
deve essere chiaro deve essere nitido
dobbiamo avere la capacità di
visualizzare esattamente in quella
situazione
quando ero giovane uno dei miei sogni
era quello di giocare nel campionato
inglese di rugby ogni settimana
trasmettevano alcune partite alla
televisione e l'atmosfera di stadi
inglesi mi catturava ecco in quel
momento non avevo idea del percorso che
avrei dovuto fare per raggiungere il mio
obiettivo non avevo idea delle sfide che
mi attendevano ma le emozioni e
desiderio dominavano i miei pensieri
dieci anni più tardi nel 2006 divenne il
primo ed unico giocatore italiano ad
essere capitano di un club inglese il
gloucester
cosa serve quindi per raggiungere un
sogno
prima di scendere in campo a common park
nello stadio di munster in irlanda si
passa accanto ad una scritta che recita
to the brain faithfull nothing is
impossible
per chi ha coraggio e fede
nulla è impossibile
per percorrere il cammino sconosciuto
verso il tuo sogno hai bisogno di
coraggio e di fede
quando mette in gioco il tuo fisico in
uno degli sport di squadra più duri che
esistono hai bisogno di coraggio di fede
in qualcosa di più grande di te la tua
nazione il club un amico
quando sei in campo devi avere fede che
il tuo compagno non ti lascerà solo
devi avere fede che quando avrei bisogno
lui sarà lì pronto a sostenerti
devi avere fede chi si da rai tutto te
stesso insieme a lui potrete raggiungere
qualsiasi meta
ecco così rugby insegna ad avere
coraggio e fede anche nella vita
affrontare le difficoltà è un po come
placcare quando una squadra di rugby
attacca lo fa con le sue abilità e la
sua intelligenza
poca perché parliamo pur sempre di
rugbisti è
mentre quando una squadra di rugby
difende lo fa con il cuore perché non
placchi una volta sola ti rialzi e
plachi ancora cadi ti rialzi e platì
ancora e ancora e ancora
può capitare anche di sbagliare un
placcaggio
anche nella vita quando seguiamo il
nostro cuore ci capita di sbagliare
ma un rugbista sa che un placcaggio
sbagliato non è mai un errore quando
l'intento è quello giusto
un rugbista sa che se un compagno
sbaglia un placcaggio è suo dovere
recuperare e terminare il lavoro
perché in campo come nella vita è
l'impegno che mettiamo che fa la
differenza quando dobbiamo affrontare
una sfida
non esiste mai placcaggio sbagliato
quando placchi con il cuore
gli inglesi che hanno inventato il rugby
ma ogni tanto si dimenticano di avere un
cuore anzi sono molto più razionali di
noi dicono putia body on the line netti
il corpo sulla linea
noi che siamo un po più romantici
diciamo getta il cuore oltre l'ostacolo
oltre l'avversario
perché sapete come fa un rugbista capire
quando ha giocato una buona partita
il risultato non c'entra nulla
un regista sa che ha fatto una buona
partita quando il corpo gli fa così male
da non riuscire quasi a camminare
ecco perché i registi portano in giro le
loro cicatrici come se fossero delle
medaglie al valore le botte i punti di
sutura sono la prova che è giocato con
il cuore
strani personaggi questi leghisti
nel 2012
subì tre operazioni nella mia spalla
sinistra infortunata si durante un
placcaggio il chirurgo e fisioterapista
continuavano a ripetermi che dovevo
dimenticarmi di tornare in campo e
dovevo preoccuparmi solo ad avere una
vita normale
dopo qualche settimana che continuavano
a ripetermi queste parole onestamente
inizia a maturare qualche dubbio anche
nella mia testa
ma sette mesi dopo ero di nuovo in campo
non ero abituato ad arrendermi non ero
allenato a rimanere a terra
mollare non era mai stata un'opzione per
me
tutto quello che so ancora fare adesso a
rialzarmi a ripartire sempre
quel medico e quel fisioterapista poi
sono diventati due miei amici molto
speciali
avete mai notato poi che un rugbista
anche dopo un grave infortunio
vuole sempre uscire con le sue gambe dal
campo
anche quando obbligato ad uscire in
barella alza pollice in aria per dire
che sta bene ma soprattutto per
affermare che lui non avrebbe voluto
lasciare il campo in quella maniera ma
erano stati i medici ad obbligarlo
perché in campo come nella vita la vera
sconfitta non è cadere a terra ma e non
rialzarsi
ecco perché un rugbista aiuta anche un
avversario a rialzarsi da terra
la cosa più importante è ripartire
sempre magari zoppicando ma ripartire
sempre
uno degli aspetti più curiosi del rugby
e il passaggio
nel nostro sport si corre in avanti ma
si può passare la palla solo all
indietro
quando spiego questa regola a chi non
conosce il rugby molto spesso mi viene
chiesto ma scusa non sarebbe più
semplice poterla lanciare anche in
avanti per segnare la meta più
velocemente
a quel punto intelligenza in rugbisti
viene messa nuovamente a dura prova
ma nel rugby si passa la palla solo all
indietro altrimenti non ci sarebbe
bisogno del sostegno
quando sostieni veramente qualcuno devi
essere dietro di lui devi rispettare i
suoi tempi devi rispettare le sue scelte
la comunicazione in campo è
importantissima ma ancora più importante
la capacità di adattarsi alle scelte
della versata del compagno
è facile sostenere quando abbiamo voce
in capitolo
quando possiamo contribuire o quando
siamo noi stessi a decidere per gli
altri
ma in campo non c'è tempo durante una
partita non c'è tempo di discutere se
una scelta è quella giusta o quella
sbagliata
in verità nessuna scelta è completamente
giusta o completamente sbagliata quello
che fa veramente la differenza e la
qualità del sostegno
per giocare a rugby serve sostegno
incondizionato durante l'azione
ma come si sviluppa questa capacità
quando passi la palla lo fai perché
pensi che il tuo compagno sia in una
posizione migliore della tua o possa
prendere una decisione migliore della
tua in fondo quando passi la palla mette
in gioco te stesso mette in gioco parte
del vantaggio territoriale che è
faticosamente guadagnato correndo in
avanti
quando passi la palla da giocatore che
alla responsabilità di avanzare fare una
scelta da giocatore che è sostenuto da
tutti i suoi compagni diventi il primo
sostegno utile perché il più vicino
proprio così
nel rugby l'ultimo che passa la palla è
il primo ad avere il dovere di sostenere
il compagno
se ci pensate
vale la stessa regola anche nella vita
quando abbiamo sostegno di chi ci sta
più vicino
familiari amici
possiamo affrontare qualsiasi sfida
possiamo immaginare di raggiungere
qualsiasi meta
anche nel rugby però non è sempre
possibile passarsi il pallone perché il
compagno non è in una posizione migliore
della nostra o perché la squadra è già
sotto pressione da parte dell'avversario
a quel punto il portatore di palla la
responsabilità di tenerla e affrontare
il placcaggio
una volta che viene messo a terra però
deve lasciare completamente l'ovale a
quel punto i compagni devono sostenerlo
per impedire che l'avversario recuperi
il pallone
dal più grande gesto di generosità nel
rugby il passaggio al più grande gesto
di responsabilità tenere il pallone
una cosa però è sempre necessaria e
sostegno
questo è il motivo per cui il giocatore
che oltrepassa la linea schiaccia il
pallone a terra segnando la meta non è
mai la superstar della squadra ma il
finalizzatore
il finalizzatore di tutti gli sforzi di
tutto il lavoro dei suoi compagni
questo è il motivo per cui chi segna la
meta non appena si rialza si volta ad
abbracciare i suoi compagni perché sa
che il merito non è solo suo e sa che
dietro di lui c'è sempre qualcuno pronto
a sostenerlo
è in questo momento che ti rendi conto
che quel sogno impossibile che
all'inizio era solo tuo in realtà è di
tutti
di tutti e 15 i giocatori in campo conta
di tutti i tifosi che soffrono e
gioiscono come se fossero in campo conta
e tutto questo va ben oltre il gioco va
ben oltre la meta
tutto questo si chiama vita
[Applauso]